okay shout out Kevin so I wanna tell I'm
curious about this journey okay so you
you go to this you go to this conference
yeah and then you start watching certain
channels on YouTube yeah I read I read
Rolo's book the first one yeah okay and
I read um the game okay Neil Strauss
yeah and then um I just watched like I
used to do like five to ten reactions a
day so I just watched a lot of people
like
a lot of content any particular channels
you mentioned a couple already oh gosh
stuff is cold if if I hear a guy that's
talking to or no not stuff is cold alpha
male strategies if I hear a guy and
watches he tells me he watches alpha
male strategies I'm like nah all right
no I know it's you're on I know it's
Iran
Uh Kevin Sammy I went on Kevin Samuel's
show I went on
um I I watched fresh and Fit I watched
um yeah there was a lot of different
like red pill channels okay what was
your appearance on Kevin Samuel's show
like did you call did you call in or
yeah
yeah I was like oh this is easy
I just felt like I was excited and
um yeah no he
he was just asking me about my boyfriend
at the time okay
um I actually did have a call with him
after you didn't see it like because
like that was on screen but I talked to
him after he told me to dump my
boyfriend at the time oh yeah he did I
did yeah
oh gosh
[Laughter]
um why why did he why did he say that
you don't have to go too personal if you
don't want to but like that's quite a
but yeah um
you don't you don't you you don't you
don't have to you don't have to if you
don't want it it's just the right yeah
it wasn't it wasn't the right you know
yeah fair enough and then when did you
start your show of the pregame
I started at February 27th of last year
okay and what was the impetus for that
that's a big word oh what what made you
decide to start that okay that's better
that's the reason reason
um it was kind of like
I I when I was in London it was the most
diverse City I've ever been in I thought
it was so cool how I can meet someone
from Italy
um the U.S Romania
um freaking I don't know yeah any
anywhere and I just thought it was so
cool that I could have all of these
different cultures in one place and even
just playing on like sports teams and at
the school like there's a lot of
international students and so I was
thinking like I could start this show
and bring in like guys and girls to talk
about like dating and different like
topics I didn't necessarily think it was
going to be like red pill
um it was more like a fun show but that
then I don't know the red pill topics
like work they're doing well and I
thought they were interesting so that's
cool and what have you learned from what
have you learned from doing it I mean
you've done how many episodes now oh
gosh um I think we're at like 80 like
roughly a little under 80. um
I've learned that like whim as women we
say a lot of nothing
and I catch myself doing it and my
ex-boyfriend would say this to me like
he'd be like shut up
and I didn't really I was like well that
was rude until I've talked to
women for months and months and you'll
just ask them and we don't answer
questions no and I'm not saying I'm
special okay I'd like to say I don't I
don't say I'm special in any of this I
do the same things
um like but I'll like catch myself
because I've talked oh shoot I've talked
to so many girls like we don't answer
questions it's like we'll move the goal
post we'll do like yeah and and we're
always late because when I'm recruiting
men and women the women like the men are
always more on time than the women and
the women it's like 50 50 if they'll
even show up like yes so I'll feel like
I'm a guy when I'm recruiting because
like you want attractive girls to come
on the show you know and I'll be like
wow I keep getting flaked on this isn't
nice
I think it's so interesting what you
said there you said that you you felt
like a guy
they don't answer the question you asked
and then they just say things and you're
like you can't just say you'll see what
we have to deal with now our whole lives
and I'm not saying men like some men do
it too but it is just not the same it is
not the same like the more I do the show
the more I think women shouldn't vote
she's going there she's going there yeah
I just I'll take one for the team yeah
I'll do it yeah you can say things that
you know I mean I I can say anything but
like you know
you've got the female privilege so some
things are better no you do too you
broke the deadlifting yeah I'm I go back
and forth on this to turn our rights for
the for the moment I'll take one for the
team the outcomes I want for this moment
in time I'm identifying as a man for my
beard you know I put the beard oil in
that's you know it's shining
um tell me some of the
tell me some of the differences you
found between the USA and the UK
in what regard
okay let's start with the topic that
we're discussing we're talking about
intersexual Dynamics and relationships
dating all of that
are there some fundamental or noticeable
patterns and differences you've seen
um
okay this this is my analysis okay of
the UK versus the US one the guys dress
better in the UK agreed yeah like I
would say overall they're more like
fashiony so so do the women but I would
say like the guys it's more like
noticeable second thing the girls here
they they still do the wild [ __ ] but
they're a little classier about it
that's my interpretation and and in the
UK it's different because everything
closes early here so I feel like The
Nightlife scene is kind of different
okay like I don't I don't drink so I'm
not even I'm not really like you know
you're not out there no no but just
okay
I don't know
oh God
they yeah because I threw you off
no because the because I just from my
I'm not even gonna go there but it's
it's interesting the UK I feel like you
have something really interesting to say
and you censored yourself
um
I I just feel like
a lot of like the the modern like
mentality is similar here I just think
the girls aren't as like I would think
in Miami it would be a lot easier to get
girls to come on the show and like say
crazy [ __ ] even though like there's
other girls that like they they think
the same way and have the same mentality
but they're not as like open yes does
that make sense that makes sense yeah so
when you talk about that mentality what
what is the mentality of the Modern
Woman the average modern woman that you
see in the U.S or in the UK how would
you describe that mentality it's like
but it's like they almost hate men okay
it's it's like a predisposition where
they just like don't like they don't
they feel like they don't need men even
though men built the world we live in as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible